Hi, Ryoko! We're just getting started.
I have you on speakerphone.
Oh, hello everybody.
Hey, Ryoko.
Hi, Ryoko.
Okay, who wants to start?
I don't like talking in public...
...or at all really.
Harold, please. The floor is yours.
Yesterday, I finished the source code for the recipe request voice interface,...
...and I ran the unit test, so that's done.
But these stand-ups are okay.
You only have to answer three questions.
What did you do yesterday?
What are you doing today?
And what is your main impediment?
Today, I am working on passing the request parameters to the recipe search code.
It's structured. It's fast.
It's painless.
My main impediment is still my lack of knowledge of the speech recognition engine.
Ryoko is our expert and she's been a wonderful help.
But with the time difference, it's just challenging.
Okay. That's very good Harold, but we need to resolve that.
Ryoko?
Hi.
Can you send me your schedule?
I will look into getting travel approval.
Okay, I'll do that.
Thanks, Ryoko.
Why don't you go next?
Okay sure.